your main shoulder joint is made up of
two bones your upper arm bone called the
humerus and your shoulder blade or
scapula
this joint called the glenohumeral joint
is where the head of your humerus fits
into the socket of your scapula
smooth tissue called articular cartilage
lines the bony surfaces in the joint
tough tissue called the joint capsule
surrounds the joint
fluid inside the capsule helps lubricate
the joint all of these features help
your shoulder move freely
arthritis is a painful disease in your
shoulder joint
the two main types of shoulder arthritis
are
osteoarthritis which may be due to years
of overuse or an injury
and rheumatoid arthritis
in osteoarthritis the cartilage covering
the bony joint surfaces becomes rough
and wears away
this allows the bones to rub together
in rheumatoid arthritis your immune
system attacks your joints
this inflames the joint tissue and
causes swelling
over time it can damage both the
cartilage and bone in your joint
the most common symptom of shoulder
arthritis is pain
as the arthritis gets worse over time
the pain may limit how much you can move
your shoulder
if you have questions about shoulder
arthritis talk to your healthcare
provider
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you